[Music]
hello I'm Greg
I'm javi Kuwait I have a chart Kirk you
know javi you know a Chara you've seen
them probably on the internet before hey
hey everyone everyone Batgirl Joss
Whedon you've all heard of this Joss
Whedon is gonna write and direct and
star in the new backdoor oh no not them
yeah you asked Greg how we fill that out
I found this out by and I've got a sound
bye jabby contacted me and telling me
which immediately proceeded with three
other text messages from other people
coming in like a like a storm do did you
hear about this and then I checked
comments and of course everyone's saying
that we should talk about this I'm
excited about it Jamie you go first well
I mean I don't I'm not as familiar with
Joss Whedon's body of work as you or
Shara but I like what he did with the
first Avengers film quite a bit and even
the second Avengers film I liked and I
think that he's just a very very very
capable director and writer and the
appropriate person to handle this
particular task
it's Shara what do you think about this
I am so excited
I love Joss Whedon as a writer or a
director I grew up watching Buffy
I like dollhouse which I guess a lot of
people didn't really rate but I enjoyed
that and I enjoy his work a lot and his
writings really snappy and witty and
funny and obviously he's really good at
doing the strong female characters as
well I think he's one of those like
active writer directors who is clearly
an enthusiastic fan of the comic books I
know many years ago he was supposed to
be the one who was gonna be doing the
Wonder Woman movie and everyone was
really jacked about that he of course
didn't end up doing it a lot of people I
don't think really saw this announcement
coming because you know like II did the
Avengers movies which was like the
biggest thing for Marvel to have done
people have always said Joss Whedon
should do a DC film he should he should
reignite it and you know after seeing
like the Justice League footage and then
seeing a lot of the way the humors being
infused it reminded me more of Joss
Whedon style and after all you know like
he did Buffy and Buffy was badass
Black Widow got introduced into the MC
with Iron Man too but I felt like her
identity really became more defined once
Joss Whedon stepped in for the Avengers
so I feel like he really knows how to do
strong female characters we all know how
great of a filmmaker Joss Whedon is we
don't need a there's no question about
that
well I think it's actually better that
he didn't do Wonder Woman because
there's some kind of established tone
and style going on with Wonder Woman
that he probably would have done
something completely different with and
so Batgirl hasn't been introduced into
you know the Justice League or anything
like that none of the other films and so
he's getting a chance to start fresh
with this character I think overly much
much smarter my question is though is
like which version of Batgirl is this
gonna be because there's many different
backdoor alliterations and of course the
most popular one being Barbara Gordon
Babs as I like to nickname her Barbara
Gordon's the most popular one but if it
is Barbara Gordon and then it makes me a
little bit more questionable but where
the timeline of the DC EU is gonna take
place because they announced the
Nightwing movie and when I grew up
reading Nightwing in my teen years
Barbara Gordon was already Oracle at the
time so now I'm a little questionable
about okay so is this gonna be a
different Batgirl that we're gonna get
that's gonna take place if it they're
going with the present time or are they
just gonna make her Barbara Gordon or is
this is this gonna be a Barbara Gordon
Batgirl story but kind of like how
Wonder Woman is an origin tale that
takes place before these DC EU events is
it gonna take place you know at the
origin of Batgirl as well so I'm just
curious as to where exactly will this
take place depending on which backer
alliteration we're gonna get I just mean
it hasn't been fully signed for even the
writing yet this is like everything is
still coming together yeah and so we
have absolutely no idea where it's gonna
start but I'm sure a lot of people are
tweeting it just we don't know what to
do yeah like please take it this
direction
everyone just needs to leave them alone
let him do his thing yeah with the DC EU
kind of be known
and developing a reputation I'm trying
not to sneeze right now constantly
replacing directors and writers I
wouldn't be too surprised if Joss Whedon
was suddenly not doing that girl down
the road you know there's so much hype
now behind this all like within minutes
of the announcement everyone's losing
their mind and is excited and I think
one of brothers is gonna recognize that
whereas with Ben Affleck it's like there
wasn't as much momentum and excitement
about him directing or even being Batman
there was all this doubt and reluctance
with him yeah yeah and so here everyone
has full confidence in Joss Whedon I
don't think it's gonna get changed I
think Warner Brothers is gonna fight to
keep him if you follow the events after
age of Ultron was released Joss Whedon
just seemed like the most miserable
human being on the planet he like left
Twitter and you just he just they just
ran away
he did like a Hillary Clinton thing he
just he just left that sounds like a
good job even and Hillary Clinton turns
into a super hero when John after after
the events of age of Ultron were Joss
Whedon had a pretty good control on the
first Avengers movie after age of Ultron
he felt like Barry wiped and he didn't
really like the experience that went
along with it that's why he hasn't
returned for anything Marvel related
this product raises the ante of
competitiveness between the DC Universe
and Marvel because Joss Whedon was the
guy who did Avengers my first billion
dollar breaking Marvel movie that and
the movie that the DC EU has been trying
to get to who the whole time you know
I'm fairly certain that when just we
didn't went into talks with Warner
Brothers studio heads he's like look
this is what I want I want this level of
freedom if you don't give me this I'm
not doing your movie and like okay it'll
give you that I'm sure it's gonna be a
kick-ass film because he's gonna have
the freedom that he wants back that he
used with Avengers who do you think
should play black huh what do you think
she maybe thinks you're a bad girl
oh come on it charts Alicia Silverstone
Darla Johansson yeah was this slightly
like um more plus-size woman she's not
plus-size but she's like known to be
like on the okay okay don't show you
Kate Upton is supposed to be actually
sirens chloë grace moretz could totally
be Batgirl
I think Chloe grace yeah and she's a
awesome awesome person for those of you
who don't know I was actually in a music
video with her and she was really nice
and she can kick ass
definitely hey guys and the kick ass
that's right yeah you got it you
understood okay well who do you think
should play back are all youtube
questions comment below yeah subscribe
to the real rejects
Jabby Kawai is on the jam eco a channel
on e and he also has the Jabby Tube
channel breakdown the difference
youtube.com slash Jeb youtube is where I
do American trailer reactions and movie
reviews
Jeb ich away is where I do the
international stuff and the Chara Kirk
is a shara Kirk on social media social
media stuff yes you're gonna text me all
the all big stuff they'll all be in the
description box and shout out to
Joycelyn Lewis Alma she's she's a
wonderful woman an angel we got a
c-section to bring this handsome man
into this universe